because there was a quarterback deal
yesterday not dak prescott but jacoby
perset he got a a two-year total deal
there was some confusion over whether it
was a two-year extension or a straight
two-year contract it is a two-year
contract he's now signed through 2020 at
a total value of 30 million they gave
him a 28 million dollar raise over the
next two years basically pre-exercised
the franchise tag on percent guys i see
this as a win-win peter your thoughts
i mean it was a it was a very smart move
by indianapolis because now basically
for the next
two years let's say
they have got their their quarterback
and their backup quarterback if you had
brian hoyer
basically locked in for 40 million
dollars
there's no team in the nfl that has
uh a starting quarterback and a backup
they love
uh for 40 million over the next two
years so look we don't know about jacoby
brissette yet i happen to think i'm
bullish on brisette i happen to think
he's going to have a good year for the
indianapolis colts and i'm picking the
colts to win that division but the
reason that they did this
is very simple you don't want to get to
week six
and either panic because uh you know
he's underperforming and he knows that
there's pressure on him for his future
in the last 10 weeks to save his career
you don't want that you want to say
you're our guy for the next two years
you're doing it and of course if he's
awful they got brian hoyer who can be a
you know a good middle relief pitcher
and who can try to save their season so
it's a good idea not only
for brisette and the colts but also in
getting brian hoyer as well yeah a
hundred percent agree i mean it's great
for the colts it's great too and it's a
little bit of a propaganda thing too i
mean let's just be real with it what
does it do oh jacoby brissett we're not
sure what he's going to be oh we are the
organization chris ballard frank reich
here's 30 million dollars for two years
look everybody in the locker room we
think this guy could be our leader the
starter of our football team the guy
that can still win games hey fans that
want your money back because andrew luck
retired look we're giving this guy 15
million a year because we think he can
lead our team i think it's all of that
included with what peter said so good
move and i certainly expect the colts to
be very competitive in this playoff race
in the afc
they looked ahead a year they did not
like what the free agency market had at
quarterback this gives them some time to
wait and see what the future will hold
and the flexibility to absorb a certain
high dollar contract that could flow
back onto the roster at some point in
time if andrew luck has a change of
heart in 2020 or 2021 so i think it was
a good move for everyone it does give
percent a lot more than the 2 million he
was going to make this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports